Guten Abend. Guten Tag.
Ja, guten Tag.
Ah, Joseph ist mein Name und ich bin für Sie zuständig auf diese Station.
Wie kann ich für Sie tun?
Wie geht es ganz schlecht?
Ich habe so starke Schmerzen hier oben in der Brust und das ist vor 3 Stunden.
Ich habe es angefangen und erst habe gedacht, es geht wieder weg.
Aber das sind solche heftigen Schmerzen und es strahlt so bis in den Untergeber hier rein.
Das ist mir ganz schlecht.
Können Sie Ihr Namen nennen, bitte?
Ja, ich heiße Ralf Kühler.
Ralf ist der Vorname, ich bin ein Mann.
Könnten Sie bitte langsam, bitte.
Und der Familienname ist Kühler.
K U Umlaut.
H L E R.
Herr Kühler, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 8. Mai 1964.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege so 87 kg.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
187.
Herr Kühler, weil Sie eine Brustschmerzen haben,
ich möchte von Schwester eine EKG schreiben lassen für Sie.
Und damit machen wir unser Gespräch weiter.
Okay, ich glaube, das ist ganz gut, weil die Schmerzen wirklich sehr unangenehm sind.
Ja.
Okay, das ist jetzt passiert.
Ich lebe noch.
Ja, und wir machen weiter.
Sie haben starke Schmerzen im Brust seit ungefähr 3 Stunden.
Ja, so langsam wird es ein bisschen besser.
Aber das war ein sehr stark brennende Schmerzen.
Das war ganz schrecklich, ja.
Ich strahlt nach eher Unterkiefer.
In den Unterkiefer hat das ausgestrahlt, ja.
Sonstiger Bereich strahlt das aus?
Nee, sonst neben so hin.
Wie hat es begonnen, langsam zu nehmen oder plötzlich?
Nee, das ging ganz plötzlich, bin einmal.
Ich habe in den letzten Monaten das schon immer mal gehabt,
wenn ich also viele Treppen gelaufen bin.
Aber heute war das so, dass ich einen wichtigen Termin hatte.
Und ich habe verschlafen und dann bin ich zu Fuß gelaufen.
Und nach einer Treppe fing es mit einmal an.
Und da war mir also wirklich ganz übel und ich habe geschwitzt.
Und ich hatte wirklich ein ganz starkes Angstgefühl auch.
Ja, sie hat dann viel Angst.
Ich verstehe, dass es sehr schwer sein.
Ich möchte wissen, ob Sie noch Husten haben?
Husten? Nee, Husten habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Ja.
Und Wischtag sind die Schmerzen, zum Beispiel auf eine Schmerzskala
von 1 bis 10, 1 am leichtesten Schmerzen
und 10 für unerträgliche Schmerzen.
Also der Müdlich, den ich schon in der 8 geben.
Das sind wirklich so bedrohliche Schmerzen, ja.
Aber jetzt ist es ein bisschen besser zum Glück.
Ja, jetzt.
Aber wie es läuft jetzt, ist es besser geworden.
Jetzt ist es gerade ein bisschen besser, ja.
Ja, ungefähr jetzt von 1 bis 10.
Ja, es tut es nicht mehr so doll,
weil 6 oder 7, ja, 6 vielleicht.
Aber so kann ich es aushalten, jedenfalls.
Die Schmerzen sind immer da, dauerhaft.
Ja, ja, also sonst sind die immer weggegangen.
Ich hatte das schon mal so, dass ich so leichte Probleme hatte,
wenn ich mich angestrengt habe.
Aber jetzt habe ich mich wohl ein bisschen zu sehr angestrengt
und dann ging es mir eben richtig schlecht.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, dass dir die Schmerzen verursacht haben könnte?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich bin in Eile gewesen und bin zügig gelaufen
und musste dann eine Treppe noch, eigentlich musste ich 3 Treppen hoch zeigen,
aber nach einer Treppe konnte ich nicht mehr.
Da fingen diese rasenden Schmerzen an.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Medikamente dagegen genommen?
Nein, nein, nein, ich nehme nur meine normalen, meine normalen Zutruktabletten,
aber sonst habe ich heute Morgen auch genommen
und meine anderen Medikamente,
aber ich habe jetzt nicht speziell dafür genommen.
Alles klar.
Und gibt es etwas, dass die Schmerze verschlechtert würde?
Ja, noch schlechter kann es ja fast nicht werden.
Ich denke mal, durch die Belastung war das.
Ich hätte jetzt die Treppe nicht weiterlaufen können.
Zum Glück habe ich dann Kollegen gleich hier hergebracht.
Alles klar.
Und haben Sie sich erbrochen oder hat Ihnen nur...
Mir war nur schlecht, ich musste mich nicht übergeben.
Ich musste mich nicht übergeben, aber ich habe mich so gefühlt als Obben.
Und das eben krass war, ich habe mit einem unglaublich geschwitzt,
obwohl das heute gar nicht war.
Ja, kalte Schweiß war es.
Ja, ich denke mal, so war ganz stabil.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie irgendwo Taupatsgefühl wegen dieser Schmerz?
Nein, würde ich nicht sagen.
Taupatsgefühl habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit abordert zu genomen?
Nein, mein Gewicht ist stabil.
Ja, und wie sieht es mit Ihrem Stuhlbank oder Walzalassen aus?
Haben Sie da Probleme?
Ja, ich habe schon ein bisschen Probleme mit der Prostata
und deswegen muss ich nachts oft auf die Toilette.
Aber sonst habe ich eigentlich normale Verdauung.
Gehen Sie oft nach heute, ne?
Ja, ein bis zwei Mal in der Nacht muss ich raus.
Ja, es war aber das Nomal Gresel.
Ja, wegen ihr Alter.
Ansonsten gibt es hier in Ihrem Vorgeschicht
wichtige Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte,
oder leiden Sie unter chronische Krankheiten?
Ja, ich habe schon seit vielen Jahren ein Diabetes,
den ich viele Jahre mit Diät und mit viel Bewegung behandelt habe.
Aber seit fünf Jahren nehme ich jetzt Metformin
und da komme ich eigentlich ganz gut zurecht.
Metformin, wie viel?
Metformin, ein Tausend nehme ich eine morgens.
Nur morgens?
Nur eine morgens, ja.
Und sonstige Krankheiten?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen hohe Blutdruck
und ein bisschen hohe Blutfettwerte.
Deswegen nehme ich einen Betablokker,
einen morgens und dann habe ich noch
in der April, das nehme ich auch morgens.
Betablokker, welche Betablokker wissen Sie?
Oh, wieder heißt, weiß ich nicht, nein.
Dosis, auch wissen Sie nicht, ne?
Ich denke, dass es wahrscheinlich ist,
dass Bilok zock 75.
Ja, Bilok.
Und Anna Laprich, wie viel Migrant?
Weiß ich auch nicht, steht auf meiner Packung,
aber habe ich jetzt nicht mit.
Und wie oft am Tag?
Nimm ich auch einen.
Einmal abends oder morgens?
Nein, ich nehme die auch morgens.
Soll ich sie lieber abends nehmen?
Nein.
Nicht gut, okay.
Ja, wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nee, operiert, kurd ich noch nicht.
Und leiden Sie an, Sie sagen,
Prostata-Probleme
ist bei Ihnen eine Krankheit, die agnostiziert?
Nein, nein, das ist nur,
dass die ein bisschen vergrößert ist.
Ja.
Und dass ich deswegen halt häufiger auf die Toilette muss.
Ich nehme da aber keine Tabletten oder so.
Alles klar.
Ist bei Ihnen eine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich eine Latex Allergie.
Da kriege ich so einen häptigen Ausschlag davon.
Latex Allergie?
Ja, genau.
Das ist mal so durch Gummi Handschuhe,
ist mal aufgefangen.
Und dann habe ich auch noch eine Allergie auf Nouragin.
Ja.
Da habe ich nicht nur so einen Ausschlag bekommen,
sondern da habe ich auch tatsächlich dann Probleme
mit der Luft gekriegt.
Alles klar.
Aber jetzt leiden Sie an Luftnot.
Ja, also das war jetzt bei dieser Attacke.
Da hatte ich schon das Gefühl,
dass ich schlecht Luft kriege.
Und nachts macht mir das auch manchmal zu schaffen.
Deswegen habe ich mir schon zwei Kopfkisten zusätzlich geholt
und schlafen ein bisschen höher,
weil ich das Gefühl habe,
dass ich dann besser Luft bekomme.
Aktuell meinen Sie?
Ja, ja, ja.
Zwei Kisten.
Und schlafen.
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine jetzt?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Dann ähnliche Beschwerden haben Sie früher oder das ist erst mal?
Nein, ich hatte immer, also nicht so heftige Beschwerden,
aber ich habe das bemerkt,
dass ich nicht so belastbar bin,
wenn ich Treppen hochgelaufen bin.
Früher konnte ich ohne Schwierigkeiten
vier Etagen Treppen laufen.
Und jetzt muss ich immer schon pusten,
zwei Treppen.
Und jetzt, heute war es dann eben ganz viel schlimmer.
Alles klar.
Und Herr Köler, rauchen Sie?
Ja, also ich rauche nur noch ganz wenig.
Seit zwei Jahren rauche ich nur noch so fünf,
zehn Zigaretten am Tag früher.
Ich habe viele Jahre lang so ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Könnten Sie nochmal wiederholen?
Früher, für zehn Jahre haben Sie 50er-Ettel-Antag.
Bis vor zwei Jahren habe ich eine ganze Packung am Tag geraucht
und jetzt rauche ich nur noch so fünf bis zehn Stück.
Und heute habe ich noch nicht geraucht,
weil es mir nicht gut geht.
Aber Sie haben wie lange geraucht?
Ja, 25 Jahre habe ich schon heftig geraucht.
Aber jetzt seit zwei Jahren denke ich mal fünf bis zehn Zigaretten am Tag,
das wird noch nicht so schlimm.
Das ist eine Routine für Sie?
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein, da habe ich keinen Kontakt.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig oder gelänglich nicht Alkohol?
Ja, gelegentlich trinke ich ein Glas Wein,
wenn es sich ergelbt, wenn etwas zu feiern ist
oder wenn man Besuch hat oder so.
Wie viel?
Ein Glas Wein oder zwei.
Ist bei Ihrer Familie so eine starke Krankheit bekannt?
Meine Mutter, die hat auch einen Altersdiabetes.
Sie lebt noch.
Mein Vater ist gestorben vor wenigen Jahren.
Der hatte auch hohen Blutdruck
und hatte eine Herzkrankheit.
Ist der wegen Herzkrankheit geschoben?
Vielleicht auch wegen Altersschwäche.
Der war 83 Jahre alt.
Verzeihen Sie bitte, welche Krankheit hatte er?
Er hatte hohen Blutdruck
und hatte eine Herzkrankheit.
Er war sehr alt.
Hast du eine Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet, bin aber im Trennungsjahr.
Mit wem wohnen Sie?
Jetzt wohne ich alleine.
Die Kinder sind schon sehr alt.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
3.
Sind Sie gesund?
Nein, einer der Söhne.
Er ist leider Epileptiker.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Innenarchitekt.
War Sie in der letzten Zeit in Ausland?
Ich habe nicht mehr.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, immer wieder.
Aber nicht durchgängig.
Sind Sie gegen Covid-19 geimpft?
Ja, ich habe 3 Impfungen bekommen.
Und gegen Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, klar.
Was haben Sie von der Corona-Krise gemacht?
Ich habe keine Angst.
Sie haben schon eine Frage gemacht.
Was haben Sie von den Kinderkrankheiten gemacht?
Ich habe keine Angst.
Nein, ich bin nicht normal durchgängig.
Wir sind unser Aufnahmegespräch beendet.
Ich werde Sie körperlicher untersuchen,
ich werde Sie körperlicher untersuchen,
von Ihnen Blut abnehmen. Man haben wir einige weitere Untersuchungen, damit wir eine besser
Bild von Ihrer Krankheit zu haben. Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich, oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen,
zu Ihrer Beschwerden? Eigentlich habe ich Ihnen ja viel erzählt und ich habe
das Bedürfnis nicht irgendwo hinzulegen, weil ich mich wirklich immer noch nicht gut fühle.
Ja, jetzt machen wir unsere Untersuchungen und werden Sie, ich hoffe auch besser.
Ja, ich hoffe Sie können mir irgendein Medikament geben, dass es mir besser geht.
Ja, natürlich nach unseren Untersuchungen. Dann, jetzt werde ich mit meinem Kollegen
sprechen und sofort wieder herkommen. Okay.
Ich habe eine andere Frage. Können Sie die Schmerzen genau bescheiden, sind die Schmerzen
brennend und dumpf?
Brennend und dumpf. Haben Sie dort brennen oder soll es aufstorten?
Darf es aufstorten, habe ich nicht. Dort brennen?
Nein, ich habe auch nicht. Schluckbeschwerden?
Schluckbeschwerden habe ich auch nicht. Nein.
Wo die Schmerzen am strechsten sind?
Hinterm Brustbein, klar.
Verdammt Brustbein. Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie ähnliche Bescheiden haben,
aber bei Belastung nur Treppen steigen.
Ja, da habe ich das Gefühl gehabt, dass ich keine Luft bekomme
und da habe ich aber nicht so viele Schmerzen gehabt.
Keine Schmerzen, nur Luftnot.
Jusuf, können wir anfangen?
Einige Minuten noch, bitte.
Wir haben natürlich das Problem, dass es eigentlich eine idiotische Situation ist,
weil man in so einer Situation natürlich immer erst mal die Untersuchung machen würde,
bevor man weiter fragt. Aber das müssen wir jetzt einfach so tun,
als ob das ist die Frage.
Ich habe diese gesagt, herr köle, diese Information ist sehr wichtig.
Deswegen möchte ich sehr sein, ob mit Ihrem Herzen alles in Ordnung ist.
Das ist gut.
Aber wir müssen Blut abnehmen.
Ja, das ist wichtig für Truppungen.
Jusuf.
Ja, können wir anfangen?
Hallo Frau Ersten, hatten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich. Sie haben einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen?
Ja, und ich würde gerne Sie vorstellen.
Herr Raich Schüller, 58-jährige Patient,
ist bei uns gekommen wegen seit 3 Stunden bestehende
plötzlich aufgetretener,
brennender und dumpfen Schmerzen
mit Strahlung in Unterkiefer.
Wo sitzen denn die Schmerzen?
Brustschmerzen, drösten alle Brustschmerzen.
Schmerzintensität ist, am 1. war 8 von 10,
aber im Laufe der Zeit etwas weniger geworden,
die Schmerzen aktuell 6 bis 10,
6 von 10, ja genau.
Die Schmerzen laut den Patienten sind an dauernder Schmerz.
Und ähnliche Bechwerden, früher hatte er nicht.
Und beim Belastung sind die Schmerzen schlechter geworden.
Und auch beim Belastung habe auch Dispne.
Schon immer, oder wie?
Nie bitte.
Hat er schon immer Dispne bei Belastung?
Nein, Dispne ist kurz zuvor.
Okay.
Früher hatte er keine Probleme dabei, aber jetzt
beim Schlafen braucht er 2,
1.
Und dagegen benutze ich mit Formin 100 Units und Atealipatoni seit schon Jahren und auch
Disziplimi.
Es wurde keine OP bei Ihnen durchgeführt und als Medikation ernehm ich auch Belogzeug
bei Bedarf einmal morgens.
Er ist vollständig geimpft gegen Corona.
Er hat Latex Allergie und Neuvalgin Allergie.
Die Allergie zeigen sich Hautausflug und sogar beim Neuvalgin auch Disziplimi.
Er hat seit 25 Jahren ein Schachtel pro Tag oder halbschachtel.
Das ist mir nicht klar.
Aber seit zwei Jahren erraucht weniger zum 50er pro Tag.
Er trinkt gelegentlich ein bis zwei Gläserwein auffeiern oder Drogenkonsum wurden verneint.
Bei Familie Anamnese zeigt sich Diabit Schmelitus bei Mutter.
Bei Mutter und Vater ist ein Alter vielleicht wegen Herzproblemen gestorben.
Das ist nicht klar.
Er weiß nicht genau, weswegen.
Er ist ein Zeltkent, verheiratet.
Er ist im Trennungsjahr mit einer Frau.
Er lebt allein zurzeit.
Er hat drei Kinder.
Er hat einen Sohn mit Epilepsie.
Er ist aus dem Ausland.
Er ist nicht im Ausland gewesen.
Erzählst du noch mal, was war der Auslöser für diese Schmerzattacke?
Früher habe er nicht so eine Schmerzattacke.
Was war denn heute der Auslöser?
Heute war er am stärksten.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf die Herzinfarkt aus.
Aber differenzial diagnostisch kommen auch Herzinsuffizienz.
Vielleicht eine Asthmaattacke, aber das ist nicht so aus.
Ich möchte eine EKG verschreiben lassen.
Dann körperliche Untersuchungen und Labo-Untersuchungen.
Was untersuchen Sie im Labor?
Ich habe eine EKG-Troponin.
Ich habe eine Herz-Echo durchgeführt.
Ich habe eine Corona-Ankrankographie.
Das ist therapeutisch.
Mit Interventionsmöglichkeiten.
Als Therapie, wenn die Diagnose gesichert ist,
Monitoring, Analliatik umgeben, Antikorgontherapie
und ein Angiografen kann man auch durchführen.
Das ist eine sehr gute Anklage.
Denen zu stenden.
Dann bin ich gespannt.
Der Patient wird schon überwacht.
Dann halten Sie mich bitte auf dem Laufenden.
Was aus Herrn Thüler wird.
Ich habe eine andere Anklage.
Ich könnte Sie wiederholen.
Ich sehe Ihre Patientenvorstellung als beendet.
Ihr Patient ist auf der Intensivstation.
Sie berichten mir nachher weiter,
was aus ihm geworden ist.
Alles klar.
Ich habe eine andere Anklage.
Was ich jetzt auffällig fand,
dass Sie diese Akkursituation nicht beschreiben konnten.
Was ist passiert?
Warum hat er diese Attacke heute Morgen gehabt?
Oder heute Nachmittag, wenn wir am Abend sind?
Warum hat er die gehabt?
Er hatte eine.
Er hat sich extrem belastet.
Er hatte Stress.
Er hat sich taupelig belastet.
Er hatte einen wichtigen Termin bei der Arbeit.
Deswegen ist er da hingelaufen.
Dann ist er auf der Treppe.
Das war zu viel.
Da ist die Belastung eingetreten.
Da hat die Attacke angemacht.
Was ich gerade schon gesagt habe,
ist eine komische Situation,
die man nicht simulieren kann.
Weil man so einen Patienten,
der erst mal an den Monitor hängt.
Das ist völlig klar.
Schicken Sie als erstes das Labor,
das Blutdruck, das Blutdruck.
Das ist eine sehr gute Situation.
Das Blut ins Labor zur Troponinbestimmung.
Das ist schon klar.
Die Anase von den.
Sehr flüssig.
Und jetzt von dieser,
abgesehen von dieser komischen Situation,
dass es eben,
dass man eigentlich erst die anderen Sachen machen müsste
und danach weitersprechen,
war das aber alles schön logisch und auch geführt.
War sprachlich auch, fand ich ziemlich gut.
Das war dann nachher nicht mehr ganz so gut
bei der Vorstellung des Patienten.
Da sind mir ein paar Sachen aufgefallen.
Und ja,
das war auch ganz gut.
eine kleine Tückel.
Sie haben gesagt, er ist bei uns gekommen.
Nein, er ist zu uns gekommen.
Ja, ja.
Und dann.
Und zwar ist er zu uns gekommen.
Wegen.
Wegen steht mit dem genetiv.
Deswegen ist die Formulierung mit Wegen immer ein bisschen kritisch,
weil wir alle mit dem genetiv einig,
nicht so besonders gut unterwegs sind.
Ja, wegen plötzlichen, enge Gefühls,
starker Retro-Sternader, Schmerzen,
da muss man immer den genetiven umziehen.
Und dann darf man am Ende nicht vergessen,
zu uns gekommen oder hat sich bei uns wegen vorgestellt.
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Man kann das anders formulieren.
Dann muss man den blöden genetiven.
Man kann sagen,
weil er hatte oder irgendwie sowas,
ja, ist nicht ganz so elegant.
Und.
Oder auch mit ist gut.
Mit kann man den Datik nehmen.
Mit starken Schmerzen zu uns gekommen.
Das ist ein bisschen einfacher.
Ja, wegen ist etwas schriftlich.
Ja, man kann das natürlich machen,
aber dann muss man es richtig machen.
Gut.
Ja, den bitter Blocker nimmt er regelmäßig.
Und ich bei Bedarf in dem Deinemorgens.
Ja.
Das und mit vom Min natürlich mit vom Min 1000.
Und nicht 100.
Eine Sache war noch.
Was fragen das noch?
Beim Rauchen.
Beim Rauchen, ja, genau.
Das ist wieder die Geschichte mit den Zeitangaben.
Seit zwei Jahren.
Raucht er nur noch.
Eine Viertel bis zur Halbpackung am Tag.
Davor.
Hat er 25 Jahre lang.
Eine ganze Packung geraucht.
Ja.
Ja, damit sind wir bei 26.
Jetzt verstehe ich besser.
Ja.
Der hat das auf ein bisschen verschwommen ausgedruckt.
Aber seit zwei Jahren rauf der nur weniger.
Aber vorher hat er immer ein Pächchen am Tag.
25 Jahre lang.
Okay.
Ja, das ist eine der großen Schücken, die Zeitangaben.
Passiert immer wieder.
Immer wieder auf in den Gesprächen.
Ein Zeitpunkt in der Vergangenheit.
Eine Zeitspanne in der Vergangenheit.
Das muss man alles unterschiedlich formulieren.
Aber dafür sitzen wir hier zusammen,
dass wir solche Feinheiten besprechen.
Okay.
Ansonsten habe ich.
Keine weiteren Kommentare.
Was sagen die anderen?
War tatsächlich ihre erste Anamnese oder nur die.